Let's continue with this example
and I welcome you to
throw examples my way, and we
can think about whether
something is consumption
or investment.
And my argument, in general,
is that investment is
something good for society.
It's good for you.
It is capital, right?
Or money that's being put to
work to create more wealth or
more capital or more
good for society.
While consumption is capital
that is, essentially, being
burned in some way, usually for
some type of social status
or ego gratification.
Well, let's think about that.
What about a going out once a
month-- Let's say a vacation,
this is an interesting case.
A simple vacation with family.
Maybe it's a family reunion,
depending on your family, it
might be simple, or it might
be relaxing, it might not.
But let's assume this is
a relaxing vacation.
You're going camping,
or you're going
to Yosemite or something.
It's a very peaceful, tranquil
thing to do.
So your original gut reaction
would be, well, if we take a
vacation, me and my family,
we're going to take time off,
we're not going to work,
my kids aren't
going to be in school.
So you might say, oh, well,
that's consumption because
we're going to spend money.
Let's say, the vacation
cost $2,000, right?
We're spending $2,000
on this vacation.
So that might be an investment,
or that might be
consumption.
So, at first you might say
that's consumption, you're not
going to be working.
Once you go on that vacation,
there's nothing left over.
But there could be a counter
argument here.
There could be an argument that,
by taking this simple
vacation with the family, it
recenters you, it bonds with
your family, it makes you
a happier human being.
And it makes you more likely
to be able to contribute to
society once you
get back home.
And if you didn't take this
vacation, you would
eventually burn out.
So in this example, and it
depends on what you consider a
simple vacation, I would
consider that actually,
probably an investment.
Especially if it makes you more
relaxed, it eases your
brain, it allows you to become
more creative and more
productive for society.
That could be an investment.
That's why I think it's
important that
people don't overwork.
Now, what if I were to take me
and my family and we were to
have someone carry us or we rode
on someone's back as they
swam across the ocean to go stay
in golden thrones while
an army of people
danced for us.
Right?
So let's say, an extravagant
vacation.
So you could argue a lot of
things, this is, I have a
family of four and let's say
it costs me $200,000.
Well here, there's
a couple things.
There might be some part of this
vacation that makes you
more relaxed and might make
you more productive.
I'd argue that it is probably
the opposite, the extravagant
vacation is probably going to
make you more stressed and
probably feed your ego in ways
that are in some ways
self-destructive.
But let's say that there is some
component, let's stick to
the benefit of the doubt,
that does relax you.
And I would say that that
component is an investment.
But you know what?
You probably could have gotten
that for $2,000.
So we could say that $2,000
of this is something of an
investment and that $198,000
of this probably is
consumption.
Because it's not making
you more productive.
Sure enough, when you go to this
place, it is giving those
people something to do and it
is giving them jobs, but I
would call that a transfer
of wealth.
This isn't investment.
When you go to whatever country
you decide to go to
and you blow, essentially,
$198,000 that you didn't need
to just because it feels good
to have the locals dote on
you, you're transferring
money to them.
And then, maybe, they transfer
that money to someone else,
but it in no way is increasing
the wealth of the world.
It's not leading to innovation;
it's not leading
to more factories; and
it's not leading to
the pie getting bigger.
And you know what?
I don't even think this is,
necessarily, a bad idea
because, frankly, this is just
the transfer of wealth from
someone who needs ego
gratification to a transfer of
wealth from someone who's
willing to do fairly simple
things to, essentially, take
that wealth from them.
But, at the end of the day,
it is consumption.
And I think you can imagine,
let's say, a simple purse.
My wife goes out and buys
a purse from Target
and it costs $20.
Is that consumption or is
that an investment?
Well, I'd argue that that's
an investment.
Maybe her old purse is falling
apart and by having a new
purse, maybe it helps her get
a job, be more productive;
maybe it helps her get
more organized.
So this could be
an investment.
And what about a Louis Vuitton--
not to pick on them
in particular-- but what about
a Louis Vuitton purse.
I don't know how much they--
I don't even know
how to spell it.
I think these cost upwards
of $2,000, or whatever.
Well, this, clearly, is some
form of consumption.
You could maybe make some
argument that in certain
circles, you could get a job
if you carry around one of
these purses.
But there's some basic core
value to it that you probably
could have gotten with
a simple purse.
So that, maybe, is $20
of investment.
And then the rest of it, I don't
know, the other $1,980,
is consumption.
Now, I'll ask you a further
question: do you think that
this is bad or good
for society?
Well, I'd actually argue that
it's probably neutral for
society, because it does look
like a quote, unquote, waste
of money, this extra almost
$2,000 that you spent that you
really didn't have to, to get
something of fairly basic
utility, but that those
resources weren't burned.
Those resources went from,
frankly, someone who just
wanted some ego gratification.
It went from someone's
ego, essentially.
So let's say this is
you, or your ego.
And this is Louis Vuitton,
the company.
So you gave them $1,980 that
you didn't have to.
Their cost of making the purse
probably didn't cost a lot
more than that simple purse.
And in exchange, they gave
you ego gratification.
So they really didn't have to
waste a lot of resources.
They gave you all of this brand
imagery that makes you
feel better about yourself.
So I would argue that this
capital actually didn't get
lost, it just got transferred
from someone who was probably
a little insecure to someone
who knows how to sell to
insecure people.
And then Louis Vuitton will then
have that $1,980 and then
who knows, maybe they give that
to their private equity
friend or their venture capital
friend, and then that
gets invested in some new
start-up idea, some solar-cell
company that actually can create
energy from the sun.
And in which case, that money
did not go wasted.
So they might actually
invest it in solar.
So this, actually, was
not a waste of money.
Although, this transaction, I
would agree, is consumption.
I would say that the waste
of money is all of the
advertising and all the
sponsorship that Louis Vuitton
has to do to convince you that
this will make you, somehow, a
better person if you
buy that purse.
Because those ads you see on TV
with those people you want
to look like, that will not
give you-- that is not
creating any net wealth for the
world, or is not making
the pie any bigger.
Anyway, let me think of
another example here.
Well, let's say, so this example
with the Louis Vuitton
purse, this is just a
transfer of wealth.
But let's say, instead of doing
that, you had your ego
and instead of buying a Louis
Vuitton purse, you just-- so
this is you-- you thought it
would be nice-- but let's say,
you thought it was nice, instead
of buying a Louis
Vuitton purse, which we
established would just be a
transfer of wealth-- it is
consumption, but at least that
money doesn't disappear-- let's
say that you wanted to
pay $2,000 to have-- I don't
know-- $10 an hour, you can
have 200 people dance for you
and recite your name and talk
about what an amazing
person you are.
This, I would argue, is
pure consumption.
Because those 200 people, sure
this money gets transferred to
them, but they didn't
do anything
productive with that time.
Right?
Those 200 people, they could
have been tilling the soil;
they could have been working in
a factory; they could have
been teaching their children how
to read; they could have
been doing something that was
productive for society.
But instead, they spent one hour
dancing for you for your
ego gratification.
And this is, in my mind, the
worst form of consumption
because, not only-- it's not
just the transfer of wealth,
it is the destruction
of wealth.
Because 200 people's time is
wealth, that is capital that
could be used to improve
someone's life.
But instead, this $2,000 was,
essentially destroyed.
Sure, it goes to those
people, right?
But in the end, they didn't
create anything in
that amount of time.
And I'll touch more
about that anyway.
In essence, the amount of money
didn't change in the
system, but the amount of
value in the system got
degraded because all these
people time got wasted.
And, In the end, that actually
leads to inflation.
If you have more money in a
system with less productive
goods and services, the price
for our productive goods and
services goes up.
But anyway, I'm out
of time again.
But I encourage you to think as
much as you can about just
this idea: when you spend money,
is it consumption or is
it investment?
And I'll continue this more into
kind of a lot of what the
government tells you to do when
the economy goes down.
How they say, go by yourself a
nice dress, instead of saying,
hey why don't you go
build a factory?
Or why don't you save your
money and invest in your
child's education?
Anyway, see you in
the next video.